okay last time
we discussed oxidative phosphorylation
which is how to couple the nadh
generated from sugar fatty acids etc
the oxidation of carbon as a way to
carry out favorable electron transfer to
oxygen
and use that energy release to charge a
battery that is
create this delta psi delta ph
that can subsequently be used by the
battery to
do work including the synthesis of atp
and of course this can occur at a
physiological atp adp ratio
and therefore allow the cell to couple
atp to adp conversion to other
unfavorable processes in the cell
now all of these reactions occur at the
mitochondria and i
drew here a schematic mitochondria for
us just to start
remember the mitochondria has its own
genome this is a vestige of its
this symbiotic relationship that
developed you know
long long ago where two prokaryotes came
together
leading to this um this
symbiotic relationship but of course the
mitochondrial dna
encoding many of the key components of
this electron transport chain
and atp synthesis machinery that remains
in the mitochondria
today now ultimately this process
involves the re-oxidation
of nadh back to nad
that occurs at complex 1 of the electron
transport chain
those electrons are transferred into the
q pool which then go into complex 3
to cytochrome c to complex 4 ultimately
being transferred to oxygen as the
final electron acceptor and it's this
process of favorable electron transport
that is electrons moving from a lower to
a higher standard reduction potential
that is coupled to the pumping of
protons and the generation of this delta
psi delta ph
now we also discussed complex two of the
electron transport chain which is
identical to
succinate dehydrogenase in the tca cycle
this is involving that fad fadh2
which can itself also transfer electrons
to the q pool
ultimately passing those to complex 3 to
cytochrome c to complex 4.
again with oxygen as electron acceptor
ultimately forming what is essentially
two different
variations on the electron transport
chain
as a way to generate delta psi delta ph
now i show here on the slide
that there's really many versions of
this electron transport chain
and another one we discussed is shown
down here so up here is the
typical one to regenerate nad plus using
complex one
to the q pool to three to c to four
here's the one
involving um complex two so succinate
dehydrogenase reaction
via complex two to the q pool complex
three
c four and then there's yet a third one
here from fatty acid oxidation so this
is acyl coa dehydrogenase again light
complex
ii involves fad fadh2 this occurs at the
membrane
transfers electrons to the q pool to
three to c to four 4
ultimately reducing oxygen to water
and so the net effect of these various
electron transport chains
or shown up here is generating this
delta psi delta ph which can then be
used to do work
now the cool thing is is that this is
occurring in this case at the inner
mitochondrial membrane
and so you can do work in lots of
different ways it doesn't have to be
next to the complex you have a charge
across the membrane
that can be used different places in
space such as
so-called complex 5 or the f1 f0 atpase
which can use dissipation of that proton
gradient
to drive that rotational catalysis
machine we described last time
and ultimately take adp plus phosphate
and synthesize
atp but that's not the only work it can
do you can
uncouple the whole thing we discussed
these uncoupling proteins which
effectively just let protons
leak back across into the membranes
that's short-circuiting
this potential and that's a way to
generate heat
other type of work we can do is we can
use this
proton gradient to power the transport
of
other ions we discussed this happening
with atp
adp exchange because of course atp and
adp conversion
needed in the cytosol the favor
unfavorable processes there
need to exchange those in and out of the
mitochondria so you can regenerate
atp with the atp synthase machinery and
yet another thing we talked about is you
can use this as a way to concentrate
ions such as
calcium and the mitochondria ends up
being a major calcium store
for cells now
we discussed last time
that this is great having all of these
oxidation processes the tca cycle fatty
acid oxidation
all occurring in the matrix because it
gives a location for
nadnadh to happen where it has easy
access to
this electron transport machinery and
the ability to regenerate the nad
necessary to keep these processes going
but of course the very first process we
talked about happens in the cytosol and
that's
glycolysis and we discussed how you can
bring
pyruvate into the mitochondria through
this mitochondrial pyruvate carrier
then it has access to the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction which of course
generates acetyl coa and nadh in the
right place
however if you go way back to when we
discuss fermentation remember the reason
we had to send pyruvate to fermentation
was to
regenerate that nad in the cytosol
that's necessary to keep glycolysis
going now of course if we're going to
fully oxidize pyruvate carbon in the
mitochondria
we still have to solve this electron
balance problem for
glycolysis and as we discussed we can
solve that by giving those electrons to
oxygen
but now you see that there's this
additional complication
is that these electrons in the form of
nadh
need to get inside the mitochondrial
matrix or get to the electron transport
chain
as a way to use oxygen
to ultimately dispose of those electrons
and so effectively
that nadh needs to be gotten to
complex one which would be the matrix um
in the
way we've drawn it here now
really the way that this happens is not
direct so you don't transport nadh
from the cytosol into the mitochondria
and that's partially because one of the
benefits remember of having
compartmentalized metabolism
is your ability to have different
conditions different atp adp ratios nad
nadh ratios
in different compartments because that
can favor different chemistry
and so the way that you get electrons
into the matrix or get electrons to the
electron transport chains
doesn't occur directly you do not
transport nad
or nadh directly instead you use
so-called
shuttles which are
analogous to some of the other shuttles
we've talked about
in order to get materials across
membranes in this case this is a way to
get
electrons generated from oxidation
reactions in the cytosol
production of nadh in the cytosol things
like glycolysis
into to the electron transport chain
so that they can ultimately be
transferred
to oxygen and so these
shuttles or redox shuttles
actually come in several different ways
that cells can deal with cytosolic
electrons
and so these shuttles
also in in essence help cells
also establish these different
conditions these different nad nadh
ratios in different compartments
and so you can imagine that the shuttles
themselves can be regulated as a way
to do this now there's two major
redox shuttles that allow you to move
electrons from the cytosol
into the mitochondria um and
we'll discuss those two here next
um these are the two that probably are
being looked for
if you get this question um
on an mcat exam or something like that
they're the ones that are described in
the text as the way to get electrons um
to the electron transport chain
but however as we go through them you
will see that
there's a couple different ways one can
do this they basically involve
oxidation and reduction of a pair of
molecules on either side of the membrane
and there's lots of ways you can do that
in addition to these
other shuttles it'll become more clear
what i mean by this but i guess i just
want you to know
that these are not the only ways one
could shuttle electrons into the
mitochondria
these are just the major ways that um
have been discussed and are usually
derived
discussed in textbooks okay so the first
shuttle system is something called the
glycerol
phosphate shuttle
and so the glycerol phosphate shuttle
involves a reaction that we've already
discussed
so here's our old friend
dihydroxyacetone phosphate from
glycolysis remember when we talked about
the
generation of and metabolism of glycerol
in order to make
triacylglycerides phospholipids remember
we
described that you can take
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
if you use nadh to reduce
that ketone to the alcohol
that generates this molecule glycerol
phosphate
and of course because you're reducing
the ketone to the alcohol something else
has to be oxidized
you re-oxidized nadh back to nad plus
effectively disposing of those electrons
from
say glycolysis that generated nadh
to regenerate nad plus okay
now rather than use this glycerol
phosphate and lipid synthesis
turns out there's a complex that can
directly
transfer those electrons
to fad
to generate fad
h2 and this complex sits
within the inner mitochondrial membrane
facing the cytosolic
side of the membrane
there's the inner mitochondrial membrane
this would be the matrix
and so transferring those electrons to
fad to reduced fadh2
reoxidizes the glycerol phosphate back
to dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and of course in this membrane you can
in this complex
transfer those electrons by re-oxidizing
the fad
and sending them to uh the coenzyme q
pool that can take the ubiquinone makes
ubiquinol
those electrons can go to complex three
that can go to cytochrome c
they can go to complex four ultimately
ending up reducing oxygen to water
using oxygen as a final electron
acceptor
again this is effectively another
alternative to the electron transport
chain
and so i show that here on the slide and
so we've discussed here's
complex 3 the fad fadh2 containing
enzyme sorry
the complex 2 this is the fad fadh2
containing
enzyme is complex 2 succinate
dehydrogenase sits
in the inner mitochondrial membrane
converts succinate to fumarate those
enzymes those electrons end up on fadh2
can get transferred to the cube pool
re-oxidizing fad
to complex three to cytochrome c to
complex forward water
uh i started to oxygen to water um
we already discussed acell koa
dehydrogenase same thing
fad containing reaction in there is also
in the membrane
ultimately allows another version
electron transport chain
and here's yet a third one involving an
fad using enzyme
the difference is is that these have the
oxidation reduction reaction occurring
on the matrix side
succinate to fumarate in the matrix size
the introduction of a
double bond for fatty acid oxidation on
the matrix side
this one here instead faces the
cytosolic side
so glycerol 3-phosphate
can be re-oxidized to dihydroxyacetone
phosphate looks like i have those arrows
drawn backwards sorry
ultimately sending electrons
into this glycerol phosphate shuttle
reducing fadh2 which can be re-oxidized
by giving those electrons to the q pool
to complex 3 to cytochrome c to complex
4
ultimately with water serving as the
final
electron acceptor as i've drawn here
now if you notice if we use
this system or any of these
systems these alternative fad fadh2
using electron transport chains you
don't use
complex one remember complex one
will pump a proton complex two will not
and that means that if you use any of
these fad fadh2
using alternative electron transport
chains you
pump fewer protons into the cytosol and
so
if you donate the electrons to complex
one from the matrix
you pump a proton as you go through
complex one to the q pool
if you go through the glycerol phosphate
shuttle you avoid complex one because
you give those electrons directly
to the glycerol phosphate shuttle an
fadfh2 enzyme
those end up in the q pool less protons
are pumped
and this is why sometimes in textbooks
you'll see that you get less atp
per nadh produced in the cytosol than
you get
for nadh produced in the mitochondria
and this helps in some of this is one of
the ways that you end up with these
accounting yields
for glucose oxidation something we'll
talk about
in a minute but the deeper reason for
this which i want you to appreciate
is because fadh2
has a higher standard reduction
potential
so the standard reduction potential
of fad fadh2
is greater than it is
for nad nadh
in essence that means that there's less
change in standard reduction potential
for transferring
fadh2 electrons to oxygen
is there is for transferring nadh
electrons to oxygen
and so less energy released less protons
pumped
and so that's why you get less atp
if you will produced going through the
glycerol phosphate
shuttle all right
next i want to discuss another
alternative
shuttle to get electrons into the
mitochondria and
this involves much more what i was
alluding to earlier and that's
oxidation and reduction of a pair of
metabolites
that are transported across the membrane
on either side of the membrane
effectively moving
electrons from one compartment
in the cell to another now to understand
how this shuttle works i have to
um it was because it's a little more
complicated i have to
first describe that there's a
relationship between amino
acids and alpha keto acids and so what
do i mean by that well
here's a alpha keto acid
that we've talked about a lot so this
is oxaloacetate remember it's an alpha
keto acid because
this ketone is alpha to this
carboxylic acid okay so an alpha
keto acid turns out that alpha keto
acids
are related to amino acids
in the following way and so
if i take that alpha keto group and
instead
make it an amino group this here
is the amino acid aspartate
now we'll discuss later in the course
the chemistry that allows you to
interconvert this alpha keto group
with this amino group but that's
effectively where your
amino acids come from how your amino
acids are related to
other um aspects of carbon metabolism
alpha keto acids
that are generated in metabolism and so
there's one example
um oxaloacetate and aspartate
an alpha keto acid an amino acid
here's another one so
so this is alpha keto
glutarate
on alpha keto acid and
if we change that alpha keto group
to an amino group
now we get the amino acid
glutamate okay let's remind you the
three-letter
abbreviation for aspartate is asp the
one letter is d
the three-letter abbreviation for
glutamate
is glu and the one letter abbreviation
is e and i just remind you of that in
case
i use those abbreviations but
effectively
you can note that if you couple
these swaps to each other that is if i
take
oxaloacetate and turn it into
aspartate
while at the same time taking glutamate
and turning it into alpha ketoglutarate
you can see that that is a reaction
where all atoms are conserved that is if
i turn this alpha keto acid
i'm sorry this amino acid into this
alpha-keto acid
while at the same time turning that
alpha-keto acid into this amino acid
i've not gained or lost any
atoms or molecules in the process
and we will see later in the course that
these types of inner conversions
is exactly how you um run
these um these reactions to do these
inner conversions between alpha keto
acids
and amino acids okay
why am i telling you this now because it
turns out this is central to understand
the other major way the other major
shuttle
which is referred to as the malate
aspartate
shuttle as another way to get electrons
on nadh from the cytosol
into the mitochondria all right so
how does this happen so here
if you have
here's oxaloacetate this is
occurring up here in the cytosol
okay and if we take oxaloacetate
in the cytosol and we
utilize
the malate dehydrogenase reaction
that we heard about from the tca cycle
so basically this is the reverse of the
malate dehydrogenase reaction we
discussed in the tca cycle
we're going to reduce this ketone to the
alcohol
nadh is re-oxidized to nad plus
that will generate
malate and now
we've regenerated nad plus
in the cytosol by putting those
electrons
onto oxaloacetate to make malate
all right now we can take
that malate send it across
the mitochondrial membranes
by a transporter to
generate on the matrix side of the
membrane
malate
whereas you know from the tca cycle we
also have
malate dehydrogenase
that can
now re-oxidize that
carbon from the alcohol to the
ketone and regenerate oxaloacetate
effectively by carrying out the same
reaction
through a redox pair on two sides of the
membrane effectively what i've done
is i've moved the electrons from nadh in
the cytosol
to now being nadh in the mitochondrial
matrix
where this can now donate the electrons
to complex one to the q pool
to complex 3 to cytochrome c to complex
4
and ultimately to oxygen just like
it would for the tca cycle
all right now the simplest thing of
course would just be to send the
oxaloacetate back out
to the cytosol but that's not what
happens
instead what happens is you turn that
oxaloacetate
into aspartate this is an alpha
keto acid turn it into the amino acid
if you do that you basically
at the same time turn glutamate into
alpha-ketoglutarate all right
turns out it's that alpha-ketoglutarate
that is exchanged
when you bring malate into the cell so
malate
is exchanged for alpha-ketoglutarate
and
at the same time you exchange
the
[Applause]
aspartate for
a glutamate
all right so now you can
take that aspartate turn it back into
oxaloacetate to do so
you need to balance this so you
return your alpha-ketoglutarate back
into
glutamate and effectively this is
the malate aspartate shuttle
okay so electrons
from oxaloacetate to malate and then
malate back to oxaloacetate moves the
electrons on nadh from the cytosol
into the mitochondria to get that malate
across the membrane you exchange it for
alpha-ketoglutarate
and to maintain carbon balance across
the whole
nitrogen balance across the whole thing
at the same time you also exchange
an aspartate for a glutamate
which allows you to um
basically interconvert the oxaloacetate
and the aspartate on either side of the
membrane via inner converting
glutamate and alpha-ketoglutarate so
somewhat confusing systems
but recognize that the net effect is
moving nadh from one side of the
membrane
to the other and that occurs because
you're interconverting
two redox pairs in opposite directions
in this case oxaloacetate and malate
on either side of the membrane and
that's why
what i alluded to earlier you can
imagine
that you could easily come up with other
shuttle systems
where you have a redox reaction on one
side of the membrane
and the reverse of that redox reaction
on the other side of the membrane
and as long as you can maintain carbon
balance the net effect is
moving electrons across the membranes
from one compartment
to another and that is a way to allow
you to
generate an adh that's now in the matrix
which has access
to complex one of the electron transport
chain
as we discussed now
several times all right now we're ready
to go through and discuss the
accounting that you
see
the accounting that comes up all the
time
that is in textbooks and perhaps you
memorized from previous classes
about how the atp yield works for
different pathways so hopefully it's
clear to you by now that these numbers
that you get
are estimates and that's because there
is no direct relationship
between nadh or fadh2
and atp these interconversions occur via
oxidative phosphorylation these electron
transport chain delta psi delta ph
and so all of these estimates take into
account
various assumptions about how efficient
the electron transport chain is
oxidative phosphorylation works
bounded of course by the change in
standard reduction potential
how much what's the free energy released
from that
what's the free energy to synthesize adp
to atp of course that those require
assumptions
and it's in the end why if you read
different textbooks and different
sources
you will find numbers that are actually
a range there is no
fixed number for what the equivalent is
of an atp for an nadh
and that's because it really depends on
several variables so
let's go through what those variables
are because if we can understand that
you really understand how this system
works so the first variable
at least if we're talking about
something like glucose where
we generate nadh in the cytosol
we have to consider the redox
shuttles and hopefully you appreciate
now that you have this need to
regenerate nad and the cytosol to keep
glycolysis going
you got to get those electrons somehow
to the electron transport chain
and i just described for you two
different ways you can do that
now if i use the glycerol phosphate
shuttle i'm skipping complex one
altogether
and so that's not pumping any protons if
i'm using the mallite aspartate shuttle
well i have all the energetics of doing
this gymnastics but in the end now i can
use complex one and pump protons and so
the yield of atp if you will how many
protons i can pump
to generate delta psi delta ph will be
different if i use the glycerol
phosphate shuttle
or a shuttle like the malate aspartate
shuttle
the second variable in consideration
is what is the efficiency
of proton pumping
by the various electron transport chain
etc complexes
that's not so straightforward and of
course is going to depend
on a couple things remember we spent a
long time talking about
atp adp and how it's the ratio of atp
adp
that was really the energy there because
remember thermodynamics is dependent on
that
you know log of the reactants over the
products term
um in the delta g equation well the
any that's true also for the nadnadh
ratio
and it's also true for how high the
membrane potential is
and so how efficient this pumping is
going to be
is going to be depending on what is the
delta side to begin with and what is the
nadnadh ratio or the fad h2 fad ratio
because all of those things will affect
how much free energy there is to be able
to move protons from one side
of the membrane to the other
once i get those protons across the
membrane then there's a question
of how and for lack of a better word i'm
going to say
tight the membrane
is to proton
leak that is you can imagine that
to make atp i have to send those protons
back through the atp synthase complex 5
f1 f080p whatever you want to call it
and if some of those protons just leak
back across the membrane
well that's how we generate heat and so
how
tight that membrane is that is how
coupled respiration
is to uh how
coupled delta psi size delta ph's to to
um atp synthesis is another variable
and of course the last one is is the
efficiency
of h plus
turning the f zero f1 atp ace
which is the same considerations we
already talked about for number two that
is
the higher delta side delta ph the more
free energy that's stored there
and the higher lower the atp adp ratio
is the easier
harder it is to synthesize
adp and so basically
these different things two through four
in general is takes into account a term
called coupled respiration
by coupled respiration is really how
tightly
is oxidation moving electrons on the
electron transport chain to oxygen
to phosphorylation synthesizing atp from
adp
and so how tight or how well coupled
is respiration to phosphorylation
really is a variable that is going to
very much
depend on conditions and so
ultimately to give numbers for what
is the atp produced from various
oxidation processes
one has to make assumptions about all of
these things how coupled respiration is
in which redox shuttles are used if it's
something
like glycolysis that involves the the
cytosol
and this is why these numbers are made
up and it's makes no sense in my view
to memorize these numbers but i think it
is
important to understand where those
numbers come from
because if you understand that that
means you understand all the assumptions
and why the numbers are variable you
really understand
the bioenergetics of what's going on in
metabolism
all right so now let's go through one of
these calculations
just to fully illustrate what i'm
talking about
so let's go through the calculation for
glycolysis so if i
run glycolysis and turn glucose into
two pyruvate so
what do we get from that of course we
get
two atps produced and we get
two nadh is produced
in the cytosol okay
so this is the cytosol
this is the mitochondria all right we're
going to completely oxidize that
pyruvate
we send that pyruvate into the
mitochondria
we run the pdh reaction that gives us
two
acetyl coa which is a yield of
two more nadhs
all right if we now take those acetyl
coas
and we burn them completely two cycles
around
the tca cycle okay now we get
two more fadh2s
and six
nadhs one fadh2 three nadhs from each
turn
as well as a gtp and so that's a total
of two fadh2s six nadhs
and two gtps and so
now if i come together what is our yield
well
from the mitochondria i've generated a
total of
two fadh2s and
678
nadhs and then up here
there's an additional two nadhs
that are made in the cytosol and so have
to access the electron transport chain
via a shuttle a typical number that's
given
is you get 1.5 atp
for something that has to access via a
shuttle
or an fadh2
that would make sense because fadh2 is
really the same as a glycerol phosphate
shuttle
and so if i do that that would be 3 atp
from the two glycolysis nadhs
and three atp
from the two tca cycle fadh2s
because the nadh is produced in the
matrix
can generate pump protons by a complex
one
oftentimes that's said to be oh that's
about two and a half atp
so eight times two and a half is 20 atp
and if we add all these numbers together
20 plus 3
plus 3 plus 2 plus 2
that is a total of 30
atp per
glucose that's completely oxidized to
co2 okay so 26 atp
over here plus another
two from gtp plus another two from
glycolysis is a total of
30 atp per glucose that is a number
it made certain assumptions obviously if
i assume
that this is not the uh glycerol
phosphate shuttle but instead the mallet
aspartate
shuttle maybe i bump this number up by
multiplying that by two and a half maybe
i use
different conversion factors and if you
read in textbooks
you get numbers that range from 30 to 36
i think the highest i've ever seen is 38
atp per glucose and the fact that you
actually see this range
really reflects that different authors
of textbooks
or whoever writes these things makes
different assumptions
about all of these things over here
to understand how to make these
conversions but the important thing is
realizing that these are not
real numbers all right let's quickly go
through and just do
the similar exercise one last time just
to come back to i'm not going to go
through as much detail but we talked
about that 6-0 fatty acid that we did
accounting for earlier
if you look back in your notes what we
wrote down is that
from completely oxidizing that fully
saturated six carbon fatty acid we got
11 atp
11 nad we got one sorry one atp
11 nadhs and five
fad h2s if we make
remember all these are being generated
in the
all these nadhs and fadh2s are already
in the mitochondria
and so if we just use the same
conversion factors
that we used for um over there in our
calculation for glycolysis
what we get is 27 and a half
atp for the nadhs
and
seven and a half atp for the fadh2s
which is a total of
35 atp
for these 28
35 plus the one so a total of
36 atp
from complete oxidation of our six
carbon fatty acid
which is certainly greater than the 30
atp we got from complete
oxidation of glucose that makes sense
fatty acids are more reduced than
glucose more calories
should be able to get more atp from it
and this calculation illustrates
that we get that the typical calculation
in textbook usually describes
complete oxidation of a 16 0
a fully saturated 16 carbon fatty acid
that's palmitate that's the one of the
most abundant fatty acids in the cell
this if you completely oxidize it the
number in a lot of textbooks
is 106 atp
per palmitate completely oxidized to co2
if you're so inclined you can go through
and do the calculations yourself and see
if you agree with that but the key point
of all of this
accounting is that none of this are real
numbers
and i hope you now better appreciate
what energy really means that is
how oxidation of carbon by being
favorable
can be coupled either to
direct charging of an atp adp ratio
as occurs in the gap dh step of
glycolysis
as well as the succinic thiokinase step
of the tca cycle
but most energy transduction involves
this charging up nad nadh ratios
or reactions that are coupled to
fadfadh2
via these membrane complexes that
ultimately lead to this favorable
electron transport
from lower to higher standard reduction
potentials
that favorable electron transport can be
used to create
a battery delta side delta ph what can
then be coupled to do other work
including synthesizing atp at the high
atp adp
ratio that can then be used by other
reactions in the cell that would
otherwise be unfavorable and allow cells
to basically extract energy
from its environment in order to fuel
the processes
that are unfavorable and are necessary
to
sustain life all right
great
so thus far we have focused
almost entirely on how you oxidize
carbon
as a way to release energy
and that's great but of course that
reduced carbon
has to come from somewhere to begin with
and every one of us learned in grade
school
that the energy for all life ultimately
comes from the sun and that's of course
photosynthesis
and now i want to turn to beginning to
discuss
photosynthesis and how it works
in other words how does life harvest
solar energy in a usable form
that ultimately involves
using atmospheric co2
which gets reduced to generate
reduce carbon that of course originally
occurred
because plants or for any photosynthetic
organism has the same issues as us
that is to fight thermodynamics maintain
and survive it constantly has to be
charging an atp
adp ratio in order to fuel the
otherwise unfavorable processes that are
required
to maintain order in the cell
this has to occur during the day when
the sun is out and there's
light energy photosynthesis but also has
to occur
at night or at times when there is no
sun and so
thus plants basically stored
energy as reduced carbon so that they
had something to eat at night that is to
keep their atp adp ratios
high at night so they can do all these
catabolic processes
at night now fortunately
for us the fact that photosynthetic
organisms stored all this reduced carbon
allowed other life like us to evolve
that is entirely dependent on
photosynthetic organisms
either directly or indirectly for food
and so photosynthesis also is the
process
that ultimately oxygenated our
atmosphere aerobic life also something
that was necessary for
us to survive because oxygen is such a
key electron
acceptor really key to our bioenergetics
well the fact that photosynthetic
organisms put oxygen
in our atmosphere also was really
essential for
aerobic life us to
ultimately evolve and so
photosynthesis is often in biochemistry
courses
almost a side light and forgotten
process
but of course it is really really
central to how life works because
no life could exist without
photosynthesis and the conditions that
allowed
aerobic most multicellular life that we
know of that's not photosynthetic
including ourselves could not have
evolved without
photosynthesis oxygenating the
atmosphere
and generating all this reduced carbon
that really is where we get
our energy from as food
now you also learned in grade school
when you learned that life depends on
energy of the sun
that the process that life uses is
this materials photosynthesis
as we go through this over the rest of
today and in the next lecture i want you
to appreciate
what photosynthesis is and that is
how life really takes solar energy
and harvests that energy in a
biologically
useful form bearing in mind
all of the concepts that we've already
talked about
because that will ultimately help you
understand
how that energy from the sun is used
to make all this reduced carbon this
carbohydrate and fat
that is energy that we can use for later
and
also of course allows how photosynthetic
organisms can
use light from the sun to just power
things directly
from that solar battery and ultimately
of course
you should appreciate that these things
all came first photosynthesis obviously
existed first
and so most of what we already talked
about well
we'll draw parallels when we talk about
photosynthesis of the stuff we already
know
of course photosynthesis came first and
the stuff you've already learned about
evolved from photosynthesis
all right now like all pathways
photosynthesis also has to follow the
same rules
and laws of thermodynamics that were
true for
all pathways so plants and animals have
to follow
the same rules and so what is
photosynthesis well it's ultimately
co2 in the atmosphere that gets reduced
to carbohydrate
that's classically photosynthesis but of
course plants also make
fatty acids okay
this is carbon reduction
remember carbon oxidation generally is
favorable
carbon reduction is not delta g
not prime for this is greater than zero
right this direction is favored that
direction is not
which means you need energy input to
reduce that co2 to carbohydrate or fatty
acid
and of course it's the sun's energy the
solar
energy that ultimately must be done
to make this favorable now we're
reducing
carbon that means we need to add
electrons
those electrons have to come from
somewhere and so we're
reducing the carbon that means something
else has to be oxidized
just like when we oxidized carbon those
electrons had to go somewhere
something else had to be reduced that
was pyruvate to lactate in fermentation
or
oxygen to water via all of the
oxidative phosphorylation things we just
talked about
and so in this case those electrons have
to come from somewhere and those
electrons
ultimately for photosynthesis
this reduction the electrons come from
oxidation
ultimately of water which will generate
oxygen and
this is effectively then the reverse
of what you learned about for the
mitochondrial electron transport
why this well water is
very abundant
has been for all of life on earth at
water sent
is obviously life depends on
water and so you can
oxidize the water
to generate um oxygen
this will obviously generate electrons
that can be used
to reduce carbon and it's
effectively the photosynthetic oxidation
of water
to make oxygen that was the source of
oxygen in the atmosphere
that really today makes aerobic lyse
possible now of course the fact that
oxygen is a good electron acceptor we've
been talking about this forever
this means that of course you might
guess that
delta g not prime for this process
is not going to be favorable
just put it another way oxygen's a great
electron acceptor and water is a poor
electron donor and so really the way
photosynthesis the magic of
photosynthesis if you will
is making water a
good electron donor
because ultimately that is what is going
to make
this whole thing work energetically
and so you probably
could guess that if these processes are
going to
are really about these electron
transfers we need electron carriers
this is true for photosynthesis just as
it was true
for oxidative phosphorylation
um but remember we'll describe a lot of
the same electron carriers are used
but as we would describe them remember
that the photosynthesis came first and
so
the other processes like oxfos that use
these electron carriers use them because
they were first used in photosynthesis
and then they were repurposed for
oxidative
phosphorylation now to discuss this
i want to first start by introducing an
electron carrier
that's important for this that's really
a variation
on nadh and it's an electron carrier
that's found in
excuse me all plants all animals all
life
and is very important in anabolic
pathways
like photosynthesis remember
that anabolism building stuff has to be
distinct from
catabolism breaking stuff down for a
number of reasons we saw this in
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
glycogen synthesis glycogen breakdown
remember delta g not prime can only
favor one direction
and so in the direction that's favorable
it works and the other direction to
actually make it happen we have to make
delta g less than zero
that has to happen by energy addition
and so now we had to have these separate
pathways you also need separate pathways
because that allows separate regulation
a voice
futile cycle and enable cells to match
needs with processes and as we already
discussed one way to keep these anabolic
and catabolic processes distinct is by
building separate
compartments right it's useful to have
separate compartments
different conditions in different
compartments that can favor different
things
happening however not all cells have
separate compartments prokaryotes don't
and you might think of situations where
you clearly want to have
two different types of reactions
happening in the same compartment
and so what if you want to both do
oxidation and reduction in different
reactions
in the same compartment well clearly
you need some way that will favor some
reactions being oxidation
and other reactions being reductions and
if you simply rely
on nadh
nad plus as your oxidant or your
reductant
this now becomes a problem
all right so a solution is
well let's make a distinct electron
carrier
for the oxidation reactions in the cells
so that's what
this is turns out you keep your nadn adh
ratio to largely favor
the oxidation reactions you want to do
and let's create a different currency
for reduction and this currency
ends up being a different molecule nadph
nad p plus and you use
this as a cofactor pair for
reduction well what is nadph
well it's effectively the same thing as
nadh but now you mark it as a separate
pool
with a two prime phosphate
on the adp portion of the molecule
let me draw it out for you
a
okay so this here is
any so i took this phosphate off this
would be
nadh put a two fine prime phosphate on
now i mark this as a separate molecule
pool
nad
ph um
a is an adenine remember it's a
nicotinamide adenine
dinucleoside okay so here's a
adenine phosphate phosphate other
nucleoside with the nicotinamide group
this here is in the reduced form
seen this now a million times but
we can oxidize it as possible
that generates this two electron hydride
ion so remove two electrons and now this
nicotinamide form
is here in the nadp
plus or oxidized
form of the molecule and so effectively
by marking this
as a separate pool with that two prime
phosphate
you can have a different nadh
and adplus ratio in cells then you have
nadph and adp plus ratio
in cells use one cofactor pair to favor
oxidation
and the other cofactor pair to favor
reduction and so i want to give
a quick aside on nadph because it's
really
also nadph that can be very important in
keeping
the cytosol of cells reduced
so what do i mean by that well remember
you learned from professor yaffi
we talked about proteins that you can
have
these inside the cytosol you'd have your
cysteine residues on proteins
be in this reduced form and outside the
cell
you'd form these disulfide bonds which
is basically
oxidized cysteine and so in the cytosol
you want your cysteine is reduced and
outside the cell
you end up with these disulfide bonds on
proteins why does
cysteine tend to get oxidized outside
the cell
well there's lots of oxygen in our
atmosphere
oxygen's a good electron acceptor it's
very good at oxidation
in fact that's what gives it this
property that makes oxidative
phosphorylation work
and so it turns out that these cysteines
these sulfhydryl groups
like to give their electrons to oxygen
and that leads to these
more oxidized things outside the cell
in fact oxygen is very good at accepting
electrons from lots of donors
okay so if you have iron two plus
sitting around outside the cell oxygen
is very good at oxidizing that iron two
plus to iron three plus that's rust
okay and this process in the end
ends up transferring electrons to oxygen
and can generate lots of oxygen species
including oxygen radicals
so you can get things like this o2 minus
superoxide
ultimately hydrogen peroxide
also
comes from oxygen picking up electrons
and as you know very reactive molecules
like this
can damage membranes damage proteins
kill cells
what do we use hydrogen peroxide for in
daily life use it to clean wounds kills
a bunch of bacteria
and ultimately production of these
so-called ros or reactive
oxygen species in excess
can be very bad for biological systems
and this is one of the arguments for why
antioxidants are good for us they
protect our us and ourselves from these
reactive oxygen species okay
now cells of course have endogenous ways
to deal with this to keep
cysteines in our cytosol reduced to keep
our cytosol in this reducing environment
prevent this
ros damage and really if you're going to
have
things to deal with these reactive
molecules what do you want well you want
something that's going to
buffer the damage that these things can
call
cause that is if these things are going
to react with lipids and proteins and
cause damage
and you want to keep the cytosol reduced
you really want to have a series of
molecules that will actually
instead undergo this process before it
can damage critical structures
in the cell and a key system cells used
to do this
is something called glutathione
so what is glutathione well glutathione
is a
small molecule tripeptide all right and
it's among the most
abundant small molecules found in
cells and effectively what glutathione
does is it serves this purpose of
reacting with
nasty stuff before it can damage other
biomolecules and hurt the cell
and so by tripeptide what it is is it's
a tripeptide of
glutamate with a gamma peptide bond
to glycine and then cysteine so
glutamate glycine cysteine
tripeptide that looks like this
okay so this here is the amino acid
glutamate
here's the um the alpha carbon
with the carboxylic acid and the amine
group so you would typically think of
the peptide
bond if glutamate was in a chain as
being from this nitrogen to the next
amino acid and that carbon
to the next amino acid but in this case
it uses the nitrogen on the side chain
the so-called
gamma linkage here to form a peptide
bond
with
whoops sorry
this would be glutamic acid it uses this
gamma carboxylic acid on the side chain
of glutamate
to form a peptide bond
with glycine
okay so this is
glutamate this is
glycine and then this has a peptide bond
too
cysteine which contributes that
sulfhydryl group that can either exist
in this reduced form or if there's
two of them together
can go into this oxidized form
and so often this is drawn as
glutathione gsh in the reduced form
and if you have two glutathione
molecules
that then basically form a disulfide
bond
to give you this gssg oxidized
form of the molecule and
nadph plays a key role in the cell
because that's an oxidation reduction
reaction
in keeping glutathione in the reduced
form so if you have two
gsh molecules that can cycle to a
oxidized gssg so
this is reduced this is
oxidized on the other side you can
cycle those electrons if something gets
oxidized something else has to be
reduced
so you can have
nadp plus and nadph
this is reduced this is
oxidized and so by maintaining
a high ratio of nadph to nadp
plus you can keep a high ratio
of reduced to oxidized glutathione in
the cell
and keep the cell in a protected
reducing environment
where you have these glutathione
molecules to
react with other things before it causes
damage
to the cell all right a little bit of a
diversion
but a very important system that cells
use related to oxidation reduction and
nadph
and needed a place to talk about it
somewhere in the course
all right now back to photosynthesis
now for photosynthesis this reduced
nadph molecule is of course useful
because it can serve
as a source of electrons to donate
carbons
to reduce co2 so if you're going to
reduce co2
to make carbohydrate or fat
you need those source of electrons those
can come from nadph which can be
oxidized
to nadp plus
and so perhaps at this point you've
already guessed or maybe already know
that photosynthesis uses the favorable
electron transfer from water
to generate nadph
and to do that you use the energy of the
sun
now of course if you're going to do a
favorable electron
transfer that can be
coupled just like we talked about for
oxidative phosphorylation
to make delta psi delta ph
and if we can use that favorable
electron transfer to make delta psi
delta ph we can also use it to do other
work
including making atp exactly
as we described for oxidative
phosphorylation
and at the highest level this is exactly
how photosynthesis traps solar energy
and uses that energy to both remake
reduced carbon
and generates a battery
for the photosynthetic organism they can
be used to make atp
or do other work provided that
sun is available and so
classically photosynthesis can really be
separated into i guess two distinct
processes
all right so you have this process
of taking solar energy
okay using that solar energy
to charge up a battery delta psi delta
ph
which of course can be used to generate
atp or do other work
and at the same time gives you
an electron donor nadph
that is useful to generate reduced
carbon
once you generate high atp adp ratio
high nadph and adp ratio
now we can use that to be coupled to do
something else unfavorable and that
would be
something like reduced co2
to generate a carbohydrate
and typically when we talk about
photosynthesis
the way it's often described is how you
reduce co2 to carbohydrate and we'll do
that too
but of course we'll then see once you
have carbohydrates
obviously it's just further reduction of
carbon to make
fatty acids and lipids
we'll discuss later how we can use those
to make amino acids which
allow you to make proteins and of course
we can also
store
those carbohydrates as disaccharides or
polysaccharides storage sugars
which is what plants do they make starch
they make sucrose etc
as a way to store that reduced carbon
so that they can have a source of energy
do the oxidation reactions
to deal with their energetic needs when
the sun is not shining
all right so let's
break down these two processes
and so to just be very explicit the
first part is basically
trapping energy to make a battery
all right and so this means that we need
to
generate delta psi delta ph
via favorable electron transport exactly
what we described for oxfos but of
course photosynthesis was first
this would then allow us to use atp to
fill our energy needs
and we get nadph if we set it up in the
right way
which is important for carbon reduction
then we need to use nadph and atp via
pathways to describe how we can use
that to reduce co2 and ultimately
produce
glucose which allows us to store energy
for later
all right so that is at a very high
level what photosynthesis is
and of course this occurs in plants
all right but perhaps more importantly
it also occurs
in algae and other
unicellular
eukaryotes
as well as in prokaryotes photosynthetic
prokaryotes bacteria
and of course photosynthetic bacteria
unicellular eukaryotes algae
these really are the heroes of life
these are the things that
life started from and generated the
oxygenated atmosphere and ultimately led
to the
evolution of higher plants but also
enabled
the formation of animal life and really
anything that lives off of
eating other organisms
just a few facts about photosynthesis
because
it's really quite an amazing process and
so
about 10 to the 17th kilojoules
at least by some estimate
of energy is harvested
on our planet from photosynthesis every
year
just to give you a perspective of what
that number means that is
10 times the worldwide energy use by all
people on earth so if you add up all the
energy that we as humans use in the
world
it is tenfold less than the amount of
energy
that is harvested by photosynthesis
by photosynthetic organisms around the
world
photosynthetic organisms when they do
this consume
co2 all right so that is removing
co2 the greenhouse gas from
our atmosphere and this occurs
on a massive scale so this is better
than any
man-made engineering solution that we
have come up with
by far and i think this really
illustrates the awesome power of biology
to solve some of the biggest problems
that face our society
today so world energy problems
photosynthesis generates a ton
of or harnesses a ton of energy
global warming greenhouse gases
photosynthesis
better than almost anything at dealing
with these
co2 that is produced however
this also illustrates what some of the
problems are and what some of the issues
are with fossil fuels because
what are fossil fuels well they're
effectively reduced carbon
that is trapped in the ground somewhere
that is effectively
old photosynthesis so these are
organisms in
you know many many many many years ago
that did photosynthesis made reduced
carbon
that was effectively trapped in the
ground and so
the fact that we're you know
photosynthesis
transduces 10 to the 17th kilojoules of
energy per year
and we're using one tenth of that amount
of energy
if that's all coming from fossil fuels
that means we're using
one-tenths of a year's worth of
photosynthesis and of course not a year
is not entirely stored in the ground
per year so that's a lot of energy and
it really comes down to
why people say fossil fuels can't last
forever
and also why the net release of these
things
can change our atmosphere because of
course once upon a time there is much
more co2 in the atmosphere
and photosynthesis over millennia
trapping these things as fossil fuels
really has what has lowered co2 in our
atmosphere to the levels that they
exist today and how basically
burning fossil fuels on the scale that
we are
is able to change our
atmosphere so you can view this both as
glass half full and glass half empty
it really says understanding
photosynthesis could be a key
to solving some of these problems but it
also points out
why some of these things might be
problems to begin with
all right now we want to discuss first
how
photosynthesis traps and energy and
you'll see that
it is similar to oxidative
phosphorylation
in many many ways okay so it's going to
occur
at a membrane
all right it's going to
involve a series of
protein complexes
where we're going to favor we're going
to couple
favorable electron transport to
along a electron transport chain to
favor
proton pumping that is going to generate
a membrane potential delta psi
delta ph
in order to do that of course we need
favorable electron transport from
something that is lower standard
reduction potential to something that is
higher standard reduction potential that
is what is going to make it favorable
allow proton pumping um that when it
generates delta psi
delta ph right we can now harness that
as a way to
synthesize atp
or do other work as we've now talked
about
a lot looks a lot like oxidative
phosphorylation and it makes sense
oxidative phosphorylation came from
photosynthesis however there's some
really big differences
between the two and that is in
photosynthesis
as i've already alluded to the electron
donor
is going to be water which will generate
oxygen and the electron acceptor
is nadp plus which will generate
nad ph um
and you might now be asking well how on
earth can this be possible
because remember the standard reduction
potential
of nadh
is less than the standard reduction
potential
of our oxygen water pair
and it's really this that makes
the change in standard reduction
potential positive
which means that delta g is going to be
negative
which is why electron transport and
oxidative phosphorylation is favorable
and can be coupled to make
delta psi delta ph
now adding a phosphate to nadnadh
does not change its standard reduction
potential in a way that is at all
meaningful
to impact what goes on and so this is
really where
energy input from the sun becomes
critical
and that is it is
this light energy from a photon
that in the end makes water a good
electron donor
such that all of these other things are
satisfied
that electron transport is favorable
going from lower to higher standard
reduction potential
with nadp plus ultimately being
the final electron acceptor such that
the change in standard reduction
potential is
positive and that really is
the magic of photosynthesis and of
course once you do that now you have
delta psi delta ph
you can use that to make atp do other
work for the photosynthetic organism and
you also get nadph which is an electron
donor
for carbon reduction and the net
result is is that you get this familiar
formula
that you learned in grade school for
photosynthesis
co2 plus water with light
goes to oxygen plus
carbohydrate which is of course
the exact opposite of combustion
right we talked a lot about how burning
wood combustion is the opposite reaction
that's favorable
lots of energy released and
so the energy input here is
obviously the opposite of that to do
this
opposite of combustion and stores lots
of energy
all right so
again i want to say why use water as an
electron donor
well because it's abundant there's
nothing particularly special about water
other than its abundance
just like we talked about in oxygen is
not
really being special other than that
it's a good electron acceptor and
abundant
um you could obviously build systems
that do something other than
oxygen and water and so there are
extremophiles out there that instead
do hydrogen sulfide
to make reduced sulfur as
a another um
sorry oxidized sulfur as a way of
doing um photosynthesis exact same
concepts
would apply is what we're going to talk
about here
all right now the parts of
photosynthesis
as you might guess are spatially
distinct
that is we're going to generate
delta psi delta ph and nadph
those are basically this electron
transport chain reactions
charge the battery etc and then
imagine if we're going to fix co2
as carbohydrate
well effectively that's come more like
what we talked about with
gluconeogenesis
that's the you know chemical reactions
that we just have to build a pathway for
like gluconeogenesis
now these two things are often referred
to as the
light and
dark reactions
of photosynthesis and that's because
the first set of reactions generating
the membrane potential and making nadph
requires solar energy inputs it requires
light from the sun
this fixing of co2 which will just use
electrons
from nadph to reduce co2
can occur of course it can occur in the
light but it doesn't need light so it
can occur in the light or the dark
hence called the dark reactions and so
these light reactions can really be
broken up into
water plus nadp plus
goes to nad ph
plus oxygen and the dark reactions
are nadph
plus co2 goes to
carbohydrate plus
nadp plus which of course
gives us our net water plus
co2 goes to carbohydrate
plus oxygen and in the next lecture
what we'll talk about is we'll go
through the details
of how these light and dark reactions
work but when we do so bear in mind that
we're really going to
follow all of the concepts and rules
that we talked about
for past thermodynamic considerations of
pathways
as well as what we've been discussing
about how oxidative phosphorylation
works
thanks